Anie Samson, Luc Ferrandez,
bonsoir. Avant le taux de
participation qu'il faudra
surveiller à Laval, qu'est-ce
que vous surveillez?
- C'est la ville de mon enfance,
donc c'est ce que je connais pas
mal le quartier dans Laval,
Laval a changé beaucoup, les
candidats actuellement, autres
que la lutte est moins agressive
à Montréal, donc les gens se
pas, mais ils ont quand même des
questions de principe on parle
beaucoup de taxes pour avoir
regardé un peu les différents
programmes, de l'augmenter au
toutes les passions, donc de le
geler, mais obtenait des
services. Il y a des défis
environnementaux, je pense que
tout le monde entend là-dessus.
Ce que j'aime, par contre si les
jeunes de 25 ans qui a déposé sa
plateformes, qui a dit : prenez
la, prenez les meilleures idées,
puis essayer de les réaliser. Ça
pour moi, c'est vraiment la
nouvelle façon de faire de la
politique, l'idée n'est pas
juste à une personne, mais si
elle se réalise la communauté.
Je trouve ça quand même
innovateur, c'est innovant, mais
il y a beaucoup de jeunes qui
sont candidats, femmes et
hommes, c'est intéressant aussi.
La lutte va être intéressante à
regarder sur le plan du terrain,
j'espère que les gens vont
s'intéresser davantage, mais les
Lavallois, habituellement, quand
c'est le temps d'aller voter,
ils vont voter.
- M. Vaillancourt, n'a pas juste
laissé derrière lui un héritage
de corruption, il a aussi laissé
un désert en matière
d'urbanisme, il en a jamais fait
attention à ce qui se
construisait et au sac se
construisait, il faisait
attention si ça lui rapportait.
Donc, la ville est un peu à
reconstruire bien des endroits
que l'on de protection des
milieux naturels sont à 2 % de
protection des milieux naturels,
les candidats visent tous
presque 10 %. Je retiens
Stéphane Boyer et Michel
Trottier, qui veulent protéger
les Arabes 7 %, ils vont
protéger aussi les golfs, et je
suis impressionné par toutes les
plateformes. On voit que le
verdissement des centres
d'achat, la canopée,
l'augmentation de la plantation
d'arbres, on est plus du tout
dans les discours qu'il y a huit
ans, ça fait plaisir à voir.
Maintenant, je m'attendais avoir
plus de grands projets
d'urbanisme pour le centre-ville
et pour l'ensemble des
quartiers, Laval...
- mon Dieu, vous êtes
discipliné. Bravo!
Je vais vous amener à mon autre
panel à 17 heures. Très bien.
C'est intéressant. Quelque chose
de moins drôle, devrait montrer
les, il y a quelqu'un qui a
envoyé un message de menace à
Balarama Holness. On va
l'écouter. Je ne voulais pas le
message parce que c'est
dégueulasse. Mais la réaction de
M. Holness, qui a porté plaint à
la police pour menace de mort.
BALARAMA HOLNESS, candidat,
mairie Mtl, chef, Mouvement Mtl.
- J'ai reçu un courriel,
une menace de mort me traitant
le mot en "n" et pour moi,
c'est comme une commotion
émotionnelle que jai eue
ce matin, ça m'a bouleversé.
Et ça m'a rendu triste et
celle-là a été au-delà de ce que
je reçois normalement.
Normalement, c'est le mot en
"n", mais là, avec la menace
de mort, puis en parlant
de suicide, je pense que c'est
allé bien au-delà de la norme
de la haine que je reçois
normalement.
- On parle beaucoup de Lime sur
les réseaux sociaux qui peut
influencer les policiers à ce
retrait de la vie politique
parfois, mais là, c'est
quelqu'un qui est allé trop
loin, qui va peut-être en payer
le prix.
- Des gens dérangés qui font des
menaces sur Internet, et de plus
en plus courante que je connais
plein de mondes qui ont goûté à
différents niveaux, évidemment,
c'est totalement inacceptable.
C'est une personne dérangée. Il
faut pas voir ça comme...
dans l'ensemble, il y a beaucoup
de courriels de haine, mais des
gens font des menaces de mort,
c'est une personne dérangée il
va en payer le prix.
- Pour l'avoir lu, c'est assez
dérangeant en politique que l'on
voit toujours le meilleur de
lui-même aussi le pire, c'est ce
qu'on a vu là. Effectivement,
les réseaux sociaux, j'en ai été
victime régulièrement dans mon
dernier mandat et c'est pas
évident, les gens se cachent
derrière un écran, disent sans
voile ce qu'ils ont à dire, ils
diraient pas en face, mais il
faut le dire par écrit parce
qu'ils sont sûrs qu'ils peuvent
dire ce qu'ils veulent, c'est
totalement inadmissible, peu
importe qu'on aime ou on n'aime
pas M. Onasse les autres
candidats inadmissible de faire
part de tels mots, je l'ai lu,
c'est quand même assez
dérangeant.
- C'est réglé, je pense que tout
le monde va s'entendre là-
dessus. Par ailleurs, les
annonces du jour, je veux en
profiter, Mme Plante promet 15
plateaux sportifs sur des
terrains vagues, dans les
engourdissements qui en ont
besoin. M. Coderre qui revient
avec un projet plus vaste :
viaduc Notre-Dame en parc
linéaire. Il avait annoncé en
fin de semaine son intention de
couvrir de Décarie dans Snowden,
est-ce que M. Coderre vise de
plus gros projet que Mme Plante?
- Oui, effectivement, le
recouvrement de Décarie et de
l'autoroute Ville-Marie, c'était
Ojala Richard Bergeron, c'est
énorme. Par contre, faire un
ilain sur la partie de route qui
est à l'est du Vieux-Montréal,
ce n'est pas un grand projet
tant que ça parce que la
structure existe et c'est
génial, parce que ça sert à
rien, cette affaire-là ne sert à
rien que ça pourrait devenir une
extension du Vieux-Montréal, ça
coûtait très cher 80 millions à
l'époque, si je me rappelle
bien, on ne voit pas où ça mène,
mais ça pourrait devenir une
promenade et si on occupe le
dessous en plus que c'est une
excellente idée. Le projet de
Mme Plante aussi est assez
révolutionnaire, pour connaître
les grands parcs et les sports,
chaque fois qu'il proposait
plateaux sportifs, c'est des
trucs à plus de 1 million est
sans arrêt à 25 millions. Et là,
on va en faire à 325 000, on va
prendre des terrains vacants,
c'est une petite révolution
aussi.
- Est-ce que vous accueillez
aussi favorablement toutes ces
propositions?
- Aujourd'hui je suis bien
content de voir que les deux
candidats ont de positions
différentes avec deux projets
différents régissent d'accord
avec les deux projets celui de
M. Coderre, c'est un grand
stationnement dans le Vieux-
Montréal, les gens se
stationnent, donc ça sert
vraiment pas grand-chose que ça
va embellir le secteur, c'est
nécessaire. Brosser le
recouvrement, et on a déjà vu
celui de Ville-Marie à l'époque
où M. Coderre était maire, donc
on a vu que c'est une
possibilité que ça puisse
réaliser, il a essayé. Donc je
pense que c'est un bon augure de
pouvoir continuer à le faire
aussi, c'est un grand projet.
Pour le projet de Mme Plante de
s'occuper des jeunes que je
trouve intéressant. J'ai
toujours dit que si on s'occupe
des jeunes que ceux qui vont
s'occuper de nous, si on est
capable de les occuper sur des
terrains sportifs que c'est
encore mieux. Effectivement,
dans certains arrondissements
qui n'ont pas les moyens de se
doter de belles infrastructures,
cela pourrait faire l'affaire
rapidement.
- Derni avant de vous laisser
aller sur la vaccination, M.
Coderre qui a peut-être pris
court, hélas aujourd'hui : je
suis pour une vaccination de
tous les employés municipaux.
Mme Plante dit : c'est moi que
la mairesse. Tour de table.
- On est tous pour la tarte,
tout le monde aimerait que tout
le monde vacciné mais il faut
avoir le pouvoir de le faire, ce
n'est pas malheureusement la
possibilité et le pouvoir de
Montréal d'exiger que ses
employés soient vaccinés. Si
Québec délègue ses pouvoirs à la
ville, on pourra la faire,
aujourd'hui, on ne peut pas
l'obliger, on peut pas faire
dans les compagnies, donc on ne
peut pas faire plus à la ville.
Même si on irait plus qu'ils
soient vaccinés.
- Il y a beaucoup de villes à
travers le monde qui exige leur
employé, Coderre en exprimant
cette idée a marqué un point. La
réaction de Mme Plante et un peu
de dire : ce n'est pas d'en
parler. C'est pas à lui d'en
parler, tout le monde convie,
mais quand même, il a mit
l'initiative soit aveugle je
trouve ça intéressant.
- Il reste 30 secondes, Mme
Plante aujourd'hui était la plus
agressive par rapport à M.
Coderre, qu'est-ce qui se passe
plage
- il reste pas beaucoup jour de
campagne.
- Je pense que Mme Plante par
rapport à M. Coderre, elle de
l'annulation, au lieu de
discuter des idées de M. le M.
Coderre discutant de la. Par
exemple va pas commencer à
prendre genre de position. Je
lui conseille de discuter des
idées mêmes si ce sont des idées
qu'on ne pas Angela Merkel à
Ville de Montréal que ce sont
des idées. D'aller sur le fond.
- C'est très apprécié que les
gens nous écrivent beaucoup,
merci à vous deux d'être là. On
sera là. Vous allez jusqu